When the intergalactic megalomaniac Thanos
came face-to-face with the quick-witted, nanotech-fitted
Iron Man in Avengers: Infinity War, their
conversation didn't quite play out how fans
may have expected it to.
Rather than watching as the hulking purple
villain questioned who the armored Avenger
was, viewers saw Thanos instantly recognize
Tony Stark by name as the man inside the red-and-gold
get-up.
Fans of the Marvel Cinematic Universe have
already come up with more explanations as
to how Thanos seems to have known Tony prior
to Infinity War than we can count - and another
intriguing idea has just been added to the
mix.
Building off of what the film's co-directors
Joe and Anthony Russo previously said about
the characters' relationship, one Reddit user
has theorized that Thanos and Tony actually
met before the events of Infinity War.
But before anyone rattles off a list of reasons
as to why that's impossible, wait until you
hear the other half of the theory.
The idea goes that Thanos and Tony will meet
again and fight in Avengers 4, duking it out
in an encounter that technically happens in
the past.
So far, most people have accepted that Thanos
recognizes Tony from the final fight in Avengers
1, remembering him as one of the heroes who
stopped his original plan for gathering the
Infinity Stones - even though he wasn't on
the ground to witness it.
It's a perception that would seem to be bolstered
by comments from the Russo Brothers on the
Infinity War commentary track, where they
said Thanos recognized Tony "from the original
Battle of New York as the person who undid
the plan."
But if the fourth Avengers movie really does
delve into time travel, then perhaps Thanos
is remembering a Battle of New York - or some
other fight - that we don't know about yet.
The theory posits that the Avengers will defeat
Thanos by travelling through time to before
his Infinity War victory, doing battle with
him in the past before the events of the third
Avengers even happen.
Interpreted that way, Thanos in Infinity War
is meeting the Avengers again, while from
their point of view, they're meeting him for
the first time.
This theory is attention-grabbing for sure,
but when you take a step back and look at
the Avengers 4 rumor mill as a whole, you'll
realize that the idea sounds pretty familiar.
Back in June, not long after Infinity War
opened in theaters for its record-setting
run, Screen Rant's Thomas Bacon posed his
own theory about Thanos, Tony, and time-travel.
Bacon hypothesized,
"There's strong evidence that Avengers 4 explores
the idea of time-travel, with the surviving
Avengers traveling back to the past.
As such, it's entirely possible that Thanos
could have met a future Tony Stark […] Going
one step further, this may well explain why
Thanos snarls, 'I hope they remember you.'
Perhaps he already knows when Stark will finally
die - because he's seen it happen?"
While the theory has mutated a little bit
since the home release of Avengers: Infinity
War, there's still enough to it to warrant
some consideration.
With set photos from Avengers 4 clearly showing
battlefields from previous movies, it's totally
possible that the end game will see Tony duking
it out with Thanos in an alternate timeline's
past.
Marvel is one of the most secretive studios
out there, so despite how spoiler-happy Tom
Holland and Mark Ruffalo have been in the
past, fans shouldn't expect anyone involved
with the fourth Avengers movie to start spitting
truths about this particular time-travel theory
- or any other Avengers 4 theory for that
matter.
For the time being, the Marvel-loving masses
can either immerse themselves in the weird
and wonderful world of fan theories, believing
a new possible storyline for Avengers 4 every
week - or they can take the Russo Brothers'
words at face value, and patiently wait for
the answers just like everybody else.
Either way, all shall be revealed when Avengers
4 opens in theaters on May 3rd, 2019.